Once Upon a Time North American League
of Legends was simply watched by more
people than its European counterpart but
last weekend we saw some viewing figures
that seemed to bring back the old meme
that the LCS is dying now even some pros
are talking about the matter let's dive
into it
look I know I've been saying we're so
close to 2 million subscribers for quite
a while now but that's because we've
been so close to 2 million subscribers
for quite a while now so if you want me
to stop saying that on repeat make sure
you're subscribed to the score Esports
and also if you enjoyed this video leave
us a like on your way out the door
cheers so we're in the middle of League
of Legends summer playoffs right now in
both Europe and North America and there
are some things that both regions have
in common over the weekend both regions
had some really hype games that went the
distance in fact out of the seven best
of Five series we saw in North America
and Europe five of them went to five
games but in some ways this is where the
similarities end for some people a
glaring difference was viewership at one
point during the simultaneous broadcast
if you were to go to League of Legends
on Twitch and see the LEC and LCS
viewing figures you might have thought
there was a glitch at a point where the
LEC was being watched by over a hundred
and twenty thousand people the LCS was
struggling to pull in Amiga 10 thousand
now some people were saying this is just
confirmation of a trend that's been
discussed for years at this point that
the LCS is dying but is that actually
fair to say well there are some caveats
to those numbers first the LEC series
between Rogue and mad Lions was well
into game five of an incredibly close
series people will tend to tune in to
watch these absolute nail biters not
only that but going into the playoffs
Rogan mad lions were the second and
third seeded teams and this game will
give one of them a guaranteed spot at
world so Stakes are pretty high compare
this to the LCS where we had the fourth
and eight seeded teams in game one champ
select of a lower bracket scrap where
the immediate prize was simply playoff
survival and putting those caveats to
one side it's also not been all doom and
gloom for the LCS recently the past few
weeks have seen the LCS make headlines
as it continues to break its peak
viewership record for this summer split
culminating with over 246
000 Peak viewers during the recent Team
Liquid versus 100 thieves playoffs match
but then the LEC has also seen new
records for the season set during
playoffs and its peak numbers were
regularly between 60 and 100 higher than
the lcs's and I know that some of you
guys watching this will already be
saying Danny Peak viewership doesn't
tell the full story and that is true
looking at Peak viewership from the
regular season you'd see that the LCS
actually fell below most of the other
regions including some minor regions the
lpls figures are often skewed as they
don't take into account China's own
stream numbers and people have quite
rightly pointed out that things don't
look quite as bad if you rank the
regions by average viewership but still
you can see here that the LCS has only
managed less than half of the lec's
average viewership alright that was
quite a lot of graphs and numbers in
quick succession there but the point is
things are looking bad for the LCS when
compared to its past whether or not you
look at average or Peak viewership it
paints a similar picture but does that
actually mean we can go as far as to say
the LCS is dying well there have
certainly been a few stories over the
past few months that people point to as
proof of that back in July there were
rumors of TSM selling their LCS slot and
moving their leaks into Europe with the
decline in popularity of North American
League of Legends given as one of the
deciding factors and that same month
doublelift got in hot water as a
co-streamer with Riot for literally
saying the LCS was dying while talking
about Riot reportedly not allowing
Bjergsen to play in Mr BEAST's ultimate
Crown tournament LCS is dying like the
viewership is absolutely dying it's
there's no there's no deny it that
everyone knows everyone can feel it why
would you not let one of if not the face
of the league
playing an event with two of the biggest
creators in the world literally the
biggest Creator in the world LCS could
not pay Mr Beast enough to like insert
one of their players into an event that
is watched by so many kids now Biloxi
himself did not confirm or deny these
events and he certainly didn't come out
and agree with double lift that the LCS
was dying but in the past week just as
this conversation has been bubbling up
once again he did speak to dexerto on
the matter he said well a lot of things
have improved on the back end on the orc
side to become more professional and
support the players in a better way that
might not reflect in the LCS viewership
but that's something that I'm really
happy about I don't know exactly why the
viewership might be lower I don't think
it's really my place but we have had
conversations with Riot they're aware of
it and have a lot of ideas on things
they can look to change within the next
few years I'm definitely hopeful that
the LCS can bounce back I mean I don't
think it's dead or Dying by any means
but viewership obviously isn't as high
as it was three or four years ago I
think Riot and the teams are going to
have to get more creative to get people
to care about the LCS and its players
again it's a characteristically
professional and diplomatic answer there
from Bjergsen but there are some
takeaways for us to look at firstly it
sounds like Riot is actually admitting
at least to some players and teams that
its viewership has suffered in recent
years and there's also that hint that
we're going to see fresh ideas and
changes coming to the LCS in the coming
years what exactly could they be this
year the LCS celebrated its 10-year
anniversary their summer promo video
reflected this Landmark it featured a
lot of old LCS Pros voyboy shifter
double lift sneaky X Smithy these are
legendary names to anyone who's been
watching the LCS since its Inception and
I think this might give a clue as to
what Riot is thinking they recognize
that those veterans represent the Golden
Era of the LCS a time when every year
seemed to have more viewers than the
last I talked to one of my colleagues
here at the score Esports he felt that
it was a bad look to feature so many Old
Pros in a promo video like this that
Riot should be focusing more on the here
and now but I think Wright is
recognizing the two key things that have
been missing from the LCS recently when
compared to those Golden Days stories
and personalities maybe I'm seeing it
through Rose tinted glasses here but it
feels like in the past players spoke
their minds more there was a bit more of
an edge to things and genuine rivalries
going on the players the teams and the
story lines felt unpolished raw and real
viewers see that and fall in love that's
how they form decade-long attachments to
these players and teams and then they
tell their friends and then the whole
thing continues to grow no amount of
flashy hype videos with manufactured
storylines about players that don't
really talk that much are going to push
the needle back to where it was so
Riot's task here is a big one they have
to manufacture an ecosystem of
personalities and stories that people
just cannot look away from but it has to
be done naturally it's an unenviable
task but it's certainly doable as
someone who's been a long-suffering LCS
fan through thick and thin I'd love to
see n a finally turn the corner
these orgs they need to have something
more to offer they need to have more of
a personality to them something that
people can latch onto and say this is my
team like I'm gonna stick with these
guys through thick and thin now and
they're not going to flake away after a
few you know rough splits